okay for people who are joining the live
stream this is a continuation of a
discussion that we're having about
microcontroller control from open
language so let's see remind me where we
got to last time
last time we finished looking at at a
sample project work sample project
documentation but I think it'll be good
if we start with the microcontroller
embed code ref page okay that yeah just
go to the guide page on external and on
external but the Wilma is it in CVS no
it's it's it's a good triple in the
packet or a repository so oh my god this
is what happened everything that's
Pacolet distributed you can't edit or
you have to get set up with stash okay
it's a different thing so we better get
that set up for my machines can we um I
have no idea
oh yeah I even that's got it set up for
my I don't know well how do you do it um
I have we looked at page I've edited
individual pages and then put it back
there but we don't know I can't I can't
open the okay so we need to get that no
no if you get the product you can't get
the sources right now you know yeah okay
it's built in X Karim okay so donkey
tools they don't do me any good no
no the pack the framework is not you
know it's not really you know it's it's
developer only and nobody else type
thing at this point well okay
so that's an issue by the way Roger you
have a lot of background wind pipe noise
okay all right so we need a solution to
this thing about
the Pacolet repository and then yeah I
think that I think do I get to the
relevant page here search for it
microcontroller kit okay okay so we went
through some errors in the way this
documentation was set up last time
hopefully those will get fixed right
Suba yes okay so Andrea is here as a
project manager right so she can make
sure that gets tracked down an Andrea
can you please make sure that the other
Roger deals with figures out something
about how I can edit Pacolet
documentation okay okay where are we
starting now this must have come up
before for you actually it hasn't
specifically okay
so last time um we were talking about
features of this design that didn't seem
right that's right okay so can you
remind me what we concluded no you want
to look at instead of having it as a
three the second argument
microcontroller instead of having it as
three sub arguments whether to use an
association and we didn't resolve those
things okay so okay
part here will be looking at where you
have your most right now that that whole
thing is the second argument yeah that's
the second argument right so this is the
inputs yes and that's the outputs and
then additional options the target and
okay so in this case the name by the way
did I store any any notes from last time
I don't think so okay all right so let's
just bring up the example that you had
previously um if you open another help
viewer you can get that happen parallel
by the way um Andrea could you also
aundrea could you also um the pink
background here could you please find
out if that's a bug it looks like a bug
yes okay fine um how do you know that
super broken in the documentation
so I cracked it down and okay so where
is the where of the examples so these
are the okay we talked about the fact
this has to be reformatted by the way
are these pictures why aren't they
clickable they should be clickable makes
sense yes I understand I understand so
I'm just saying they should be clickable
so let's make sure that happens
okay so how do I
see this yeah yes so I send you the
notebook last time so okay so you need
to send it to me again I want to see it
again please I know I want to see it
because it's a good example so we can go
through to look at it we go through the
design okay and we spent some time on
some device framework editions which
will watch specifically do we have notes
from the previous meeting okay so what
was the thing for the device framework
the device submit maybe wanted to okay
can I see this example please okay so
was this the same one we looked at last
time well this is your inputs and
outputs yes and that's not how for
example the way that GPIO works right
it's different if I'm not mistaken in
GPIO it says 0 goes to serial ok fine
and why are we not doing that here
because there is just this input and
output mm-hmm that is like a very
elementary thing so a particular channel
can be both input and output okay so but
but no but what we're saying here is the
input channels
I'm not mistaken should be like an
association that says because you can't
repeat the pins right we can't repeat
the pins Billy what what does it mean
when there's an input pin when there's
two copies of input pin one suppose it's
an SPI input so on the same pin the
input from different devices connected
to the microcontroller will be coming on
the same pin okay the way the
microcontroller distinguishes which one
it is is by setting another pin low or
high
okay now have I been saving this
someplace or not I do not see you saving
anything last time I'm gonna start
saving this under ILD um I guess I'll
save it under a microcontroller okay so
that's a drea that's some for you okay
um okay all right so I'm then you also
have these options here right well it's
for each type of input and output
channel there are certain options
correct yes um so one question is kind
of hard to represent all of that stuff
ah I think look the way that we've
typically done this in other places
would be to say that the the simplest
form is this but then there's a more
decorated form that says something like
type cereal
you know max value whatever this is the
way it would work for an interpreter for
example by making sense yes now the way
it would also work for an interpreter as
you could say restricted so for example
we could say restricted integer coma 10
would be a way of just saying
give me an integer less than ten all
right so the typical case would be the
name and then let's say restricted
integer ten am I making sense okay so
that that's what we do in the case of
interpreters right so an interpreter we
say as an error if the you know so if I
say interpreter you know restricted okay
if I say that but if I say eleven here
it'll fail mm-hmm okay so that will be
another metaphor for these kinds of
things if there's a but I think this is
the best thing to do is to have
something where you say one arrow serial
if that's the simplest case or you say
one arrow and then an association which
gives all the properties of that of that
pin by making sense because when we
typically talk about channels we're
talking about multiple pins working
together in tandem okay yeah so we say
that there is this pin and I think what
we could also do it like that we could
say that that is the slave select pin
the slave select pin would be a key is
the slave select would be a key in that
Association you showed above okay I
don't know what slaves select does I
mean so are you saying that there are
multiple pins that should be together in
this association or what in that channel
that one goes to that Association so is
that a channel or a pen a channel is
made up of one or more pins okay but is
that is that one representing a pin yes
okay so how do I put multiple pins into
a channel some of some of them are like
as as those keys and sometime
if I'm giving a differential input like
an ADC sometimes that's differential
input I'll give that first one as a pair
as their as both the pins okay so are
you saying then that you would like
something which says one two arrow blah
blah blah possibility yes okay to
represent a multi pin combination yeah
okay seems reasonable to me but now when
you refer to that in the in the
microcontroller here how are you
referring to that input in the in the in
the code for the microcontroller how do
you refer to that input so go back to
the rest page so I can explain here yeah
so right after that second table you see
so when we say just the list of inputs
and outputs those read where the
position where they occur is mapped to
the position of that sis the in is just
map serially to the positions of the
inputs and outputs of that first
argument but I also have a design which
is a little below where your Mouse's the
input goes to yeah so if so that way I
can say the first input of sis goes to
these this channel or the fifth input
goes to that I don't know when these are
referenced in the code what does it look
like in other words if I'm making a
state space model the the the first
element of the state space model because
the state space model is referring to
different things by positionally if I'm
not mistaken correct so so in this case
the state space model has two inputs and
two outputs so that's find it there's a
positional that's the main point right
yes right okay so so we should explain
so so here okay so what has to happen
ultimately is that the input list and
the output list okay what do you mean so
a channel okay so if I'm understanding
correctly the state space model has a
list of channels as its inputs and
outputs is that correct yes okay
so okay so these are channels Pacifica
okay so that isn't okay input and output
channel specifications okay so the first
argument the state space model with a
list of inputs and outputs the second
argument is the microcontroller with its
list of inputs and outputs and how these
two are mapped together is based on
position so that I get it I get it okay
so the state space model has just so I
understand okay the state space model is
basically in a first approximation some
kind of generalized matrix is that true
yes okay so if I take this state space
model here like say this one here right
yeah so now how do I feed it um okay so
channel one what do I do to actually do
something with this yeah so this one has
because that you see that B it has only
one column so it has one input okay so
how do I give it an input and see what
it does here its output response if you
want to I'm sorry what do you mean how
do I get no simulate this with an
particular input in Mathematica which
you simulated we use output response
okay so there's a function output
response alright okay so our response of
that to send 30 so you won't get
anything it's just purely symbolic it's
it's a different it's a system of
differential equations Stephen okay fine
so let me take this case here okay
that's a little too simple maybe but
well okay but I just want to know what
what do I feed in this input unit step
okay that's different the unit step of T
right here okay so if I change that to
let's say I changed that to 1/2 and this
2/3 here not knowing what any of these
things actually mean okay cool okay
right so this is saying that state space
model when I feed it that input unit
step of T it will generate this output
yes right
okay terrific okay so now the analog of
that here is that I'm feeding the state
space model so instead of getting input
in this case this is the output response
from a simulation of this but in a sense
I could equally well be getting input
where this instead of this being unit
step of T this is the voltage on you
know port on wire such-and-such is that
right that you step could be coming
through that wire yeah okay so fine so
let's understand how that works so what
you're saying is that this is the state
space model is the first argument yes
and now what I want to do here is give
it this is hooking up well so just if
there was two inputs to this state space
model what would give me a version of
the state space model that would require
two inputs what you're seeing that PWM
to speed has two inputs well I
understand but where is the P okay where
where is PW on that you were just
discussing see you see that PWM two
speed inputs encoder s what does that
mean yes so encoder s see that is just
it's just a scalar on top okay all right
fine so some you can do encode er has to
be 0.5 that's what it is
okay sampling period is what one alright
so now I can say output response of that
state space model and again what do i do
how many inputs do I give here to input
okay so I could say unit step of T and T
for example okay so and and this one has
two outputs so it's going to give mr. to
okay fine so if I put in something there
okay dandy okay fine yeah and this and
this one it turns out is just that it's
just multiplying that matrix it has no
memory so it's just that matrix times
unit state can I can I give it to memory
just so I see what's happening yes so in
the first
so in the first argument just give a
random real of 2x2 matrix but here to
change everything
um I don't know for this instead of that
null list what what do i do instead of
the null list I do what are you give a
2x2 matrix there okay so everything
should be a 2x2 matrix the first second
and third all three of them
okay okay okay so if I just say random
real say size let's say going from minus
5 to 5 let's see I want a 2 by 2 by 3
correct um and now I want that I just
want to I'm going to do this in a very
el cheapo way I just paste it in there
right
yes okay what happened there can you
just copy-paste just the state space
model and evaluate it wait a minute I
got this wrong this is try
supposed to what it should be I should
have said three - two - much better
sorry about that
yeah it's going to do a symbolic
simulation it's going to take some time
why is it doing symbolic simulation wife
can I because okay so now if I were to
like plot those as a function of T but
there's nasty imaginary parts there okay
so if I just say plot that T goes from
what from what to what magnificent okay
so what is this doing this is driving
the thing with the unit step and that's
asking with unit step and a ramp the T
is a ramp Piercy the III right I get it
okay all right okay fine
okay I understand you know but you don't
need to get it symbolic if you have T in
some team and team acts I think it uses
numerical simulation much faster okay so
if I do the same thing again for the
output response and I say to you from
zero to five yeah okay so that was
because the sampling period was 1 but
let's say I said the sampling period was
point O 1 then I'll get a whole bunch of
things that why are those numbers so
ridiculously huge answer ramp and it's
might be unstable you might have two
things going on you still huge means
it's unstable used at the dynamics it's
it's what you call chaos or some people
call chaos it's sensitive to initial
varies and so that's just a feature of
this particular choice of of matrices
and so on
is that right yes ok so why is it
consistent to give functions in this
case and to give lists of values in this
case why is this not an interpolating
function this is this free time system
so it's sampling okay so if I got rid of
the sampling period it would give
interpolation function yes so that was a
you know when you use sample period it's
a difference equation system of
difference equations right it's kind of
yucky that that it goes such a different
structure but anyway okay fine so that's
beautiful what that did there I think
it's yucky that it gives a different
structure in the two cases I mean I
think it should give something which is
where somehow it's the values but ok
let's let me not go chase that ok so
then I've got a state-space model here
and the sampling period is the clock
rate of the microcontroller is that
right yep so there there is a default
sampling period if I if I don't give the
sampling period when I when I embed code
the thing it will just go to the
sampling frequency to the clock
frequency of the microcontroller yes no
it will not accept systems that are not
discrete-time the first argument has to
be a discrete-time system why because
that's the only thing that makes sense I
don't understand why doesn't it
discretize it by virtue of the fact that
it is sampling it a certain clock right
but discretization should use well
whatever to whatever is appropriate for
that particular microcontroller
you know it that's ambiguous because
because that that sampling field is like
a design criteria so if you use too high
a sampling period there are certain
advantages if there is too low there and
so on so that's the trade-off that the
design yeah but I I don't understand the
the state-space model we should be able
to state the continuous time state space
model then the question of what sampling
period is given is a question for the
actual deployment in a particular
microcontroller if I'm not mistaken no
it's it's it's like a trade-off so if
they used to to higher sampling period
the system could be unstable there won't
it won't sample fast enough if I do it
too fast I know I understand I got it
but the question of what the sampling
period is is determined I can't have a
sampling period that is faster than my
microcontrollers clock speed right fine
I understand but what you set is the
sampling period depends on what
microcontroller you're using if you
could using a microcontroller that cost
one cent and that only can run at a
certain speed you know Stephen you you
need to actually design if you're gonna
discretize something you need to see are
you gonna be able you and you want to do
that in Mathematica or Wolfram language
you want to analyze it see can i in fact
control it with this slow sample speed
sample rate and I understand slow or and
there are other issues to happen that
Suber was trying to explain when you
sample too fast which is that you can't
run it all right but the point that I'm
making is I don't understand you know is
that something which should be part of
the model or is that something that's
part of the embed code to specify the
sampling period I think that it should
be part of the model I think it's a
design choice okay fine all right fine
go wild and too unpredictable if you if
we if it just you know but there must be
very okay so is it the case that most of
these things have the possibility of
going out of control so you yes all
right all right fine all right so let's
take a look now at this okay so this is
saying I am going to compile that state
space model for this micro control
and stick it on this port yes
and that microcontroller is connected
through that yeah I understand I
understand so there's as we talked about
before that's like boot you know some
kind of analog of the bootloader for the
microcontroller so that as soon as this
has been done the microcontroller will
be ready to run if I'm not mistaken
right yes if we're ready to run and
we'll just run that state space model
mm-hmm yes so but there's no way we
don't have to say clean out the
microcontroller and and re repopulate it
it's just it's just an override override
overwriting goes to flash memory it's
just origin okay and all
microcontrollers work that way they they
don't have like I can switch between for
programs or something on a single micro
controller no yeah okay okay so all
right so what we talked about last time
as I recall to me the fact that it's
just sitting a list is kind of weird I
mean it would make more sense to me if
there was some kind of microcontroller
head that could contain all that stuff
internally I have it another simple
microcontroller channel that holds that
well what I'm suggesting is that this
microcontroller thing would be a rapper
so can you not ask questions about the
microcontroller so for example I might
want to if I if I had a symbolic
microcontroller thing right I would have
something I mean to me I'm not wild
about that list there I mean to me I
think it'd be much better I think we
talked about this last time to say you
know type or we know no you know inputs
blablabla outputs blah blah blah am I
making sense I would change that name
type to target because that's what makes
Muslims okay is it really
it's sitting right there it is a target
okay all right okay okay so there's a
whole compilation that happens now for
that target yeah okay okay so now if you
did this that you don't have in these
options the additional options to the
microcontroller which are things like
what what you see from that okay so fine
so then this would say ADC arrow blah
blah blah exact correct yes
how do I know what the possible values
of the ADC specifications are that's not
really an adequate way to document okay
but that's not the right way for us to
document this so so someplace I mean
really probably what we should do is
have pages for each of these things
ultimately um okay so what is the
programming mechanism yes that is it so
that's not a third argument so yeah the
third argument to embed microcontroller
chord P so first I explained cysts then
we explained microcontroller and then we
are getting to P so now when you go to P
you're going to the next argument so I
think by the way we don't say
Association as a link that we just say
as an association just like you would
say as a list okay okay okay so now okay
so these are not attributes of the
microcontroller these are attributes of
this particular programming of the
microcontroller like the board rate is
the speed at which the program will be
sent to microcontroller exactly yeah and
so that's why we have it there so it
distinctly so when the microcontroller
is operating suppose it has a serial
port then and that time it has to have a
baud rate that is given in the serial
channel and that's distinct from this
portrait okay so
so then that third argument so you're
saying so ultimately we might have a
thing that says microcontroller embed
code microcontroller blah blah blah no
that's not part of that that's part of
the microcontroller the first argument
would be a system oh yeah yeah so it's a
state space model it's that right
typically is the word transfer fun
transfer function model okay all right
fine so then there's my conclusion yeah
okay so then there's the microcontroller
um and then there's a list there's a
further Association which could also be
a list of things that say things like
the baud rate now what where are these
options going clean intermediate options
are options to the function itself so
after that's after explaining P those
are options to M okay but we can't have
string options so so why are those not
connected here why does not here because
these things so these the last table
that you see yeah those option names
come from other places in the system
like create executable and and so on
working there there's already the
symbols like working directory and so on
well that's not a symbol it's a string
there's a string yeah the string a
string okay so what you're saying is
this is now the list of programmer stuff
so that programmer in this sense like
baud rate or whatever right and then as
a final argument this list of options
but that's not going to work because
options are not string named things you
understand what I'm saying
function options aren't string named
things it's not how we set it up okay so
a couple of things so if you do that
then you're breaking precedence with
embed code how does embed code work and
but court only has three arguments and
all the rest after that is so you're
telling me I'm being inconsistent
if you add one more argument no look
options for embed code are symbols you
understand okay these are not symbols we
don't use strings as options because we
can't document that do you understand
what I'm saying the second point so
that's that that string working
directory it's yeah it's already used by
create executable it's already used in
art no no so that's fine it should be
done a symbol here but but but then
there are problems with all the other
staff here because you probably used him
in a different setting or meaning you
know said what are you talking about I
mean I don't understand these are not
are you saying that there are other
functions that use the same names
yes which other functions are they say
for create executable can you look at
create executable I hope that's not your
function no okay that's part of it some
other that's part of some package for KC
compilers and this will also be a
package for microcontroller I understand
I understand but that's not this isn't
why was that by the way and andraia
could you please report the fact that
that doesn't have a thumbnail image okay
Andreea please please make sure that
that that you communicate that to Brian
and he gets that fixed did you
understand what we were talking about
yeah underneath details right okay all
right so the
is breaking our usual conventions and
it's not really a great idea yeah this
is not really the right thing to do
you know in modern times these should be
in an association I would say completely
yes for system functions and we can do
it for a for a for a package - yeah I
know I know this is sloppy and it
shouldn't be this way but you know I
guess you can start out this way I mean
you can continue supporting it later but
I think it should be in an association
we're making sense so we you understand
what I'm saying and somebody's saying
yeah is there a problem
it breaks presidents I don't care I
create executable is wrong and should be
fixed but create executable is surely
going to be built you know changed when
the when the compiler comes in right
am I making sense yes then it's probably
wrong okay okay fine fine I understand
so it's not your mistake somebody else
started making that mistake but let's
not propagate the mistake okay
I mean you can go ahead if you want to
and treat these as options for right now
I don't like it
but we better to put them in an
association but then Andrea we're going
to need to go through and clean up all
the rest of these making sense yes and
that I mean that's that's a different
project we don't need to solve that
right now okay yes that's fine I mean
you can support having it in in roar
options as well just for fun okay I'm
making sense yes okay all right so now
with respect to this the question is do
we want to put this in an association I
think we do I do not think we want that
naked list there
I think as a courtesy we could have a
lower list but it should turn itself
into I mean I think this is a better
better thing to have especially since
then you can ask for properties of the
microcontroller object
am I making sense it's our problem with
this going to do nothing it's gonna sit
there it's symbolic representation or
microcontroller it does nothing but it's
it's more than a microcontroller it's
the mapping from your input it's
specific to that state space model that
you gave the mapping I see the
microcontroller just having the
association is all right fine fine okay
fine okay let's talk about these inputs
here okay so again what I think we
should do is something like this my
making sense so that that input there so
it's going to basically say inputs arrow
and then it's going to be a list of
those inputs and in the case where for
example two is a pure I don't know what
it what it says you know analog I don't
know if that's a possibility yes then we
can do that but in the case where you
want to be more specific and you want to
give options you turn it into an
association that make sense yes it does
it makes it more consistent or more
readable okay so let's see what else
have to figure out here so this then
returns microcontroller code data so
this has sent it as a side effect to
that port is that correct yes what
happens if I don't want it sent to the
port
I just want to generate the code but do
not want it sent to a port yes often
create binary goes to false oh for God's
sake and then but then what happens to
the third argument it's it ignored it's
ignored that's a really cruddy design
well we weren't targeting that case okay
so that case is not is that case not of
interest yes yeah well then we should
have another function
is it is it of interest or is it not of
interest the case will we just generate
the code we have some interest
okay the C code but not the next level
down because then you can you can then
edit that code you can inject outer
things I see okay but it's it's not a
main you know it's alright okay so fine
so but so what that would be is
something like I mean embed code
normally as a mechanism for returning
well normally embed code
turns a string it does not have a side
effect and send it anywhere well this
one actually embeds it and and then we
can ask a property at the source code
and it will give back the source code
okay I think this name is wrong then
okay this isn't the embed code gives you
the embed code this is actually these
are embedded code this is what the
embedded code is no no I I understand I
understand but the function embed code
gives you the embed code if you
understand what I'm saying
in other words it gives you the code
which for embedding what this is doing
it is actually embedding the code yeah
exactly
I know but so the meaning of embed code
is different in these two cases in the
other case embed is an adjective
right meaning code which can be embedded
yeah in this case it means actually send
it to the microcontroller yes right okay
so I think the name here is wrong well I
I think that's wrong too because I think
look okay okay hold on what is the
action of sending code to a
microcontroller called embedding code it
is yes it's embedding the code or
uploading the code to the
microcontroller okay well I think that
would make a bit but this function okay
so we've got two operations that are
going on here we've got generating the
embed code right yes this is which would
for which we would return either we
would return this thing here correct
yeah okay so we've got this there's no
board rate stuff or anything like that
there right in fact the last arguments
is it correct that the last two
arguments are irrelevant or is it not
correct or is this this argument here is
irrelevant if we're not actually sending
it to a microcontroller correct this
argument is relevant some of it like I
squared C SPI and so on okay so that's a
bit of a mess
okay because we've got a situation where
where this one here we still want the
complete thing the one-liner thing of
course if you want to build two separate
of course we do of course we do but but
I'm trying to understand this thing here
is optional and depends on the fact that
it is being sent specifically to the
microcontroller right whereas here the
effect well what code is built for the
microcontroller I'm a making sense is
that correct yes right
but that's determining what this return
value will have in it correct yes okay
whereas these options here do not affect
what is in that return value is that
correct we could say from which compiler
we used and so on because this is to do
with communication to the controller
right okay so that is communication and
you should say rather than call it P why
don't you call this communication or
something coms
comm or something like that and using P
communicating with the microcontroller
using this thing right yeah p4 port
that's way but it's not a port the
serial port for example but it's not a
oh there I see so that says connection
port okay well okay fine but that's okay
so the thing we have to do so I mean one
thing that we have might be called
generate microcontroller code and that
would then produce this microcontroller
code data make sense okay and the other
one could be something like upload
microcontroller code okay
what could happen is upload
microcontroller code if you give it
instead of a state space model where
well actually it's the first two
arguments that are being replaced by the
microcontroller code data is that
correct yes okay so that's a little bit
of a mess again right because what we're
saying then is that in upload Sandra our
live stream is pointing out that it's
often called programming the
microcontroller which is obviously true
but although programming doesn't really
say whether you're doing the embedding
or not
yeah it does so the programming is to
find that it loads it up on the flash
and manages that whole isis's because
there's a weird name it's a totally
weird name but you get used to it after
a while right okay um okay so let's
let's look here so then upload
microcontroller code would either take
the directories of the state space model
or it could take microcontroller code
data which had already been produced did
you know someone saying oh you're trying
to have a save one function well why
don't we address the whole thing I'm not
saving one function I'm saying I'm
saying look look this function here okay
where you going but why don't we just
have a third function that does the
whole thing and that's the short one
you know these we can have these
separate functions if you want that you
take it apart now but I think we should
have one that happened okay if you
really want to do that it seems silly to
me I mean okay upload okay so this
upload would then take the MCD the
microcontroller code data together with
the UM program know together with
together with this together with the the
you know dev TTY whatever right
together with whatever the specification
is this specification here you have
outboard rates and so on
I'm not making sense
like like we'll take as an example here
board right yeah but why did you split
that - because the baud rate and the
connection port are all together the dev
TTY the baud rate oh I see so then yeah
the documentation was okay okay so what
you're saying is there's a default baud
rate is that correct so if you just give
death TTY it takes that to be connection
port goes to death TTY that's just
synthetic sugar-butt so you're telling
you there's a default board rate right
because you're not specifying the baud
rate then am I making sense so when we
say Arduino Uno we should send oh you do
yep
so this board right here is overriding
that board register exactly okay all
right okay fine so there is a default
board rate as I was saying yes but the
default board rate is actually automatic
um because it depends on the the the
microcontroller that you referred to
right yes okay okay so upload wouldn't
say wouldn't return microcontroller code
data it would return success am I making
sense yeah did you understand I mean
because it's doing upload it's doing
something with a side effect right good
it could failure or success so it's a
little weird right that this thing here
the combined one is returning this
microcontroller code data even though it
had a side effect I don't think you'll
use these separate functions unless you
run into trouble no I understand why
that's why I was trying to make
something okay look having something
where the way you get out the string is
by setting some weird option
and then it produces a completely
different structure of result isn't I
agree so we've just defined two new
functions right but then you're telling
me that when nobody's ever gonna use
them well I'm not saying that but I
don't think it's a mainline use case
okay but so let's figure out what the
mainline use case is that doesn't have
some wacky thing okay so this mainline
use case is using as its success
indicator returning this microcontroller
code data object is that right yeah dos
dos those colors there are indicators
they might be red and then one of the
stages failed yes I understand I got it
I understand I understand okay fine so
that is the alternative so are you
suggesting that this upload function
returns one of these things instead of
successful failure no death one can very
well return success or failure if we
design him but it's it but I but I don't
think that the complete one should you
should still have you shouldn't be
forced to use these other functions that
you didn't understand that I got it I I
actually don't think that one needs I
think it is I think this function could
do the whole thing loads what I'm
proposing is that you have two
possibilities for what this has as its
first argument one possibility is you
give it a state space model and this
target information by making sense the
other possibility is you give it a
pre-baked microcontroller object no no
no you're not understanding the point
okay what I'm telling you is this look
this function right yeah no let's do it
more carefully right it's not a good
idea to just say automatic for the
second argument right because I know
because you know it because it's in the
microcontroller code data right yes
okay so alright now we were also talking
okay so this huge mess here right we
were talking about how to avoid that
huge mess
what was the answer to that okay well so
so just so I understand this is the non
autonomous mode of using the micro
controller right because yes this
produces an autonomous micro controller
you can just deploy on the moon and
it'll keep doing what it's doing right
correct okay whereas this is pinging the
micro controller and trying to get it to
do something right yes okay so just so I
understand okay so we still need to
clean this design here but I'm let me
just go back to the guide page okay
what's micro controller targets really
the right place to put it in is that
really the right why isn't that dollar
micro controller targets because you can
give it that name there yes that's not
usually the way we would do something
like this
well devices as a precedent if I say
devices I think
you connect something don't tell them
this will hang oh there we go okay so
those are device objects on my machine
that'sthat's trying to scan my machine
for devices what is the difference
between devices and find devices I don't
believe this is the correct form here
this this would mean what
microcontrollers are connected to my
machine not what microcontrollers are
supported by the system I mean the more
common would be something like dollar
import out dollar import formats right
that would be the more common way to do
this but I make him sense yeah but if
you want to enumerate everything like
this it's going to get out of hand so
what's your point your point is you want
to enumerate them selecting the ones
that start with the word Arduino if you
just give an empty argument then we can
give the list of vendors if you just
open scope you can see some other
possibilities okay I think this is a
hacky function okay so this is a
completely hacky function I mean okay so
where is this data coming from this is
this is built-in stuff in the system
that's defining what what possible
targets there are is that right yeah
because once we start supporting
something we add it to this list I
understand I understand where else are
we
situation like this we have a situation
like this in system information to some
extent Roger where else do we have
something like this this is I this is
gonna be potentially very large so I'm
not sure yeah system information is yes
see see I mean like for example okay so
what we would normally do is some kind
of entities things so so for instance if
I say entity list of quotes elements for
example I'll get a list of hopefully
chemical elements right so another
natural way to do this we'll be using
the elements the the entity system
making sense know what you don't stand I
understand but
but how isn't that overkill no not
really because that way if we use the
entity system okay
then for example we can go and get this
80 mega blabbered layer treated as an
entity have properties of it so you can
ask things about that microcontroller
okay so the good news is that it's super
easy to make this work okay all we do is
we take we make use entity store ok you
literally just put these lists into
entity store and you'll make this work
you go what I'm saying and that way also
for this so any one of these things then
that you've already got the information
you need ok if you if you want to
understand how entity still works you
could ask like Tony Schindler or you
could ask anybody in the wolf mal for
group um this is the right solution and
this will be quite nice sexually so and
then as a courtesy what you can do in
the microcontroller functions and you
take a string the string will be the
canonical name for the entity the entity
would be something that says you know
entity microcontroller type probably
microcontroller or a microcontroller
type and then one of these things right
Adafruit mentor let's say that makes
sense
and I mean look I can I can show you how
to do this it's really really really
really easy and you basically just give
a list of entities there's the list of
entities then you give properties of
each entity okay now these things here
become entity classes again you can ask
any other people works on entities store
how to do this it's like super
straightforward make sense yes into
resource object no has nothing to do
with resource object okay because
because we're also thinking that we
wanted to actually create like web pages
for each and populate them great you can
do that so there is a okay what we've
done with okay that that's a different
approach right okay let's talk about
this okay
is there code associated with each of
these microcontrollers what do you have
to store associate with each
microcontroller so right now
microcontroller targets only stores
these names but with each
microcontroller internally we restore
the default operating voltage or proc
frequency the pin Maps and so on okay so
things that yeah okay so those would fit
naturally into the entity system okay
the alternative is to say that each
microcontroller is its own Island okay
so okay let's talk about the two cases
the resource system is intended for
something where there is a like for
example net models okay I mean I do
think that this might fit into the
resource system in some way because
let's see I mean so so here for example
right you could imagine that each
microcontroller appears on this page
right and it is not
natural yeah I mean here it's not really
an entity property story it's a story of
there's one big blob of stuff that it's
coming out of that it's being stored in
the repository so for example if you had
the drivers for a microcontroller the
repository might make more sense am I
making sense yes okay with entities the
way that we're doing documentation for
those is right now we'll have a page for
an entity type which will list sample
entities like for example for cities we
don't list every city and have a page
for every city instead we have a page
for the entity type City on which we
list sample you know 200 sample cities
or something
making sense because there's very much
uniformity in the way that those things
are treated right
whereas here for the neural net
repository every neural net is its own
completely separate story so if these
microcontrollers are pretty much you
need to know the operating voltage the
frequency whatever else there's like a
few attributes you need to know about it
then it will naturally fit in an entity
store if on the other hand each
microcontroller sort of sings and dances
in a completely different way and if
they're not sort of compatible okay so
the neural nets you see this this is you
know some random neural net that looks
at visual images right I could look back
here and I could find some other neural
nets that is about speech recognition
right so the operation of those neural
nets is utterly different in those two
cases am I making sense okay so on the
other hand in the case of cities every
city has the same basic properties by
making sense so which is the right model
for microcontrollers because each
microcontroller will have a set will
have also a table which describes what
are the input and output pins available
and how can how they can be configured
okay fine so it's really tabular data
it's not something where every every so
for example when you if you make
documentation pages
these things you know is it the case
that the Arduino lilypad simple or the
Arduino lilypad what would be different
between the Arduino lilypad page and the
sparkfun red stick page so probably the
number of pins possibly the operating
voltage ok fine but it's very structured
data it's not the case that one of them
you say this one you know you don't
because because for the neural nets
right every neuron that has a completely
different piece of documentation get
what I'm saying
yeah because this is doing you know it's
got an audio capture and this and that
and the other whereas if you were doing
that for your microcontrollers these
separate documentation pages will be
incredibly monotonous if I'm
understanding correctly no no I
understand but it's just tabular
information like the population of a
city and things it's not you know it's
not saying this is a network that does
speech and needs to be programmed this
way versus this is a network that does
something else right ok fine then I
think the right thing is an entity store
ok go find out how to make entity stores
and as I said just so we're not confused
the the um what am I saying the the in
your actual code you can use a string
instead of the entity instead of the
actual entity as a kind of courtesy and
we're making sense and it will just
convert it into the entity do you
understand ok so let me show you an
example so you make sure you understand
ok there so I think we have a thing
called country data although it's almost
so I could go ahead and I could say
country data of France comma population
if I wants it to ok right so that will
give a result but now I can also get the
entity France right and then I could
just say this if I want to and hopefully
it'll give the same result interesting
they're slightly different
this is older um and but I can also take
this okay and do that okay
get what I'm saying but so this is a
courtesy usage but the real usage is to
have an entity that right so that's what
I'm saying you should do with in the
case of these functions of yours
make sense probably the entity type will
be microcontroller I would think you
might need a separate one you might need
microcontroller and microcontroller
vendor possibly I don't know fine well
then you might need a thing called
microcontroller family you might need
another entity type called
microcontroller family I'm gonna have to
leave fortunately we're over time but I
uh I also in fifteen minutes late to
something why don't you I mean the UM
we we're very close to finishing here um
I I would prefer not to have to schedule
yet another meeting for this um okay so
you're gonna turn this into an entity
store go find out how to do that you're
going to need three entity types
probably based on what you told me make
sense yeah okay with respect to this the
only thing that I think is left hanging
here is the way that these two functions
work right yes and
okay so so here this microcontroller
code data is something that you can then
query right but those things that you're
querying are different things and the
things that went in to the micro to the
generate microcontroller code correct
they can be like the default values that
were used and so on so if the user for
example didn't specify that operating
voltage I understand I understand I
understand but the things that you can
ask for here are things are all the
things that you can ask for here like
standard error I don't think that's
something that comes that's something it
comes from the the actual
microcontroller type not from something
that you fed in in the microcontroller
in the generate microcontroller code
function is that correct yeah the
standard error comes from actually
invoking the compiler and saying if
there was some error in compiling the
code and so on that information is
coming back to the standard error but
that's a bad name for this that that's
the output on standard error right yeah
it will be standard error log or
something will be the right name for
that standard error itself means
something different right exit code
means what it means right it's the same
thing as it's used with exit code you
also get standard error a standard
output and so on that's the same symbols
that are same strings that are used here
no I don't sent the strings are those
strings coming from from what is it
called
run process okay okay okay fair enough
okay all right so the one remaining
thing is what to name this thing here
and how to deal with the fact that
you're giving two arguments here because
you're giving both the model and the way
that that model is packet is mapped to
the microcontroller correct yeah so it's
a model and the mapping right so it's
model and mapping and the alternative is
that microcontroller code data contains
both the model and the mapping right
right so just to understand the argument
sequence here we've got I mean if we
were going to say we'd say
microcontroller um I can't spell that
word um okay so if I say upload
microcontroller code there will be the
model the mapping then the next argument
is the communication communication info
and the final argument is what the final
argument is what it's the options that
you're giving for what did you
understand what I'm asking
option it stops about what are the
external devices it's it's a mixed bag
what's the external devices connected
what is what are the compilation options
and so on okay so that is that why is
that not part of the communication info
because because what is connected is for
example that any device that is
connected to the microcontroller is
distinct from how the how the food
itself is uploaded to the
microcontroller okay so this is
uploading method basically that argument
is uploading method is that right yes
okay and the final argument is what it's
just the disjointed collection of
options this way options for compiling
the code there options that relate I'm
meeting the city chairman I gotta go
okay it's it's options for how to it's
options about how to compile the code
its options about what are the what are
some of the devices connected to the
microcontroller and so on okay does it
relate is it factored from that option
there or is it is it is there a what is
the difference between things that go in
this option versus things that go in the
general options only what is being
uploaded so it's not what's being up
there it has nothing to do with what's
being uploaded it has do things like
board rates right that's the speed at
which is
I'm well aware right but and this has to
do with on the microcontroller no the
programmer name comes from where the
problem so the programmer is is a
software in the tool I know that I know
that why is that different from the
compiler name why is it a different kind
of thing from the compiler name because
they're two different no no I understand
that they're different I want to know
what is the difference between this
block of options and this block of
options okay so those block of options
the uploading mechanism those things are
completely just for uploading whether
it's uploaded through that connection
port or that baud rate or the programmer
and so on the compiler stage happens
before the uploading okay fine fine so
all of this is happening before the
uploading yes okay so really these
options are but but those options do
they are they relevant to generating
microcontroller code without uploading
they are aren't they there yeah okay so
would it make sense to add those options
in here where you've got what we're
calling mapping right now they're two
distinct things because see for example
look at that I squared C so I squared C
that can be I squared C that can be
properties of the I squared C data for
the microcontroller that come in the
second argument that I squared C which
is now the option of the fourth argument
refers to I squared C devices that are
connected to the microcontroller they're
two different things I'm sorry so the I
squared C here
globally effects they are external I
squared C devices they are not the
microcontrollers I squared C and what do
you mean by external ones because
because there can be I squared C devices
connected to the microcontroller as
opposed
the ones that are used for uploading to
the microcontroller so the
microcontroller itself has an I squared
C bus and it's communicating to various
external eyes squad C devices so squid
sees properties that are for the
external devices we specify using what
is highlighted but I squared C
properties that are inherent that are
part of the microcontroller itself go in
the in the second argument okay didn't
quite understand that but I squid C so
so so the microcontroller itself is an I
squared C device it can it has say an I
squared C feature that is talking to
another I squared C external device
external to it so we have to configure
now both these devices both the
microcontroller and also the the other I
squared C device connected to the
microcontroller so what what ever
specification we need for the
microcontroller goes in the second
argument and that option what I have my
squared C is specifying things for the
external things external to the
microphone right okay look the only real
issue we have here is that we've got two
arguments in one of these functions on
one argument and the other function two
arguments and we've also got this
ordering that doesn't make any sense
because the uploading method doesn't
make any sense for generate
microcontroller code right so let's walk
through what we do have so and these
arguments here they do make sense for
generate microcontroller code yes or no
some of them do some of them don't you
humph okay so in in general then so this
would be model mapping and then random
options basically is what you're telling
me yes okay
humph how to do this you see the problem
write that here did you get the problem
right I may be the the more fundamental
issue is actually renaming that function
to something else microcontroller embed
code I know we want to do that we need
to rename it okay so look this is a way
that would solve that problem although
I'm not sure it's the best not sure it's
beautiful is to put those in a list okay
yes then then we would have something so
then here we would always be able to say
then this would work I mean okay so that
the two cases are so that has your
random options then this function it
compulsorily has this has this thing
because otherwise it doesn't know what
to do right yeah that correct yes yes
okay and then then the third argument
becomes the options I think this is a
reasonable solution okay okay two
functions two functions generate
microcontroller code which does that
this one if it really goes splat I guess
it could return a failure object I don't
know whether this should return I mean
if you think it's convenient to return
the microcontroller code data from
upload microcontroller code I guess we
can do that it's a little bit of a hack
it's a little bit hacky I think it
should because I'm not quite sure
whether that microcontroller code data
also contains information about
uploading code it's possible there one
or two I have to I have to double check
it's possible okay
well
find I mean then okay if no into two
functions right so all these examples
that we just had at one line are now
going to be two functions no they're not
no they're not no listen to what I said
right the whole point of making that
able to be one argument there is that
you can also do this do you understand
oh I see okay got it okay right it's
just one function in that case okay okay
so we'll have a prod microcontroller
code and then I also create an under
utility generate microcontroller code
that's correct and the way that we deal
with that because this can generate a
microcontroller code data so in the case
where you've got a microcontroller code
data out from upload microcontroller
code then what you could do is take that
and say upload microcontroller code
again for example let's say you want to
program ten Arduino is to do the same
thing am I making sense yes then I
assume that what you could do is use
upload microcontroller I mean the best
way to do that would be to say generate
microcontroller code get the
microcontroller code data then run this
ten times with different devices right
yeah mm-hmm but the other way to do it
this sort of weirdo way to do it is to
do an upload microcontroller code once
get them I could controller code data
then take that microcontroller code data
and rerun upload microcontroller code
with the different devices make sense I
think it's a decent die I think it's an
improvement all right I think we are
done here very bad you stole this
notebook I'll send it to you or Andrea
can send it to you she knows where it is
um do you all of you have access to
Dropbox
super probably is not um I'm copying you
ah somebody from our livestream before
we hang up makes a very sensible point
why not have a connection object that
describes the host port and connection
parameters making it independent of the
code being uploaded yes that is what we
are doing that's some we could have an
actual connection object but we just
have an association right now that
represents that and yes it is
independent of the code being uploaded
that was in fact the points of my whole
big fuss here um okay so the remaining
thing that has not been addressed is
improving the the device framework to be
able to deal with making this much
simpler yes and and you believe that
device submit is basically the way to do
that but device submit is the analog of
device execute but for asynchronous
operations is that correct device
execute is what will send I mean this is
unbelievably grotesque this this whole
thing here I mean what device submit
would do is it could define certain
events but I don't even know what those
events are because you've got all kinds
of weird stuff of Terminator bites you
know start bites and end bites and so on
these bites actually being part of the
device object itself to begin with and
then so it automatically knows these
things so what the start light from the
end bite is but how okay so you do a
device submit I mean the way submit to
stuff works if you look at URL submit
for example right you
these things work yes
no but sessions submit a little
different from well I guess it's it's
the point about URLs submit is it has
particular um the following events can
be generated body received blah blah
blah right so those are the things that
you respond to okay so the point here is
that what you're presumably doing is
you're responding to certain events that
certain bytes were received if I'm not
mistaken and so for example what you can
respond to then is I don't know whether
this is start bites and bites so that's
a cereal packet or something was
received is that correct yeah what
you're seeing there's your writing so
it's you're writing that out okay fine
but then then okay so why isn't device
right
the why try to do that why is it have to
be a synchronous with submit yeah
because we are both reading and writing
so this so we we first read and then we
write okay but isn't that a synchronous
command the synchronous operation to
read again okay why do you think that
this should be asynchronous why is there
a a this whole operation you you want
the whole operation to be happening at a
certain rate is that correct yes okay
that is a different thing from device
submit is not going to do that because
in device submit you're going to have a
scheduled task as the first argument
just like in session submit okay why is
it
from session submit they wanted a
different name discussion because they
thought it was not appropriate to have
and we also will need to specify the
port to which it's connected the device
which is connected I understand but the
the session submit has the feature that
is submitting um let's see does it go to
the same kernel or to another kernel
there's local submit yeah okay so this
is going to the same kernel this is
being executed in downtime of the
current kernel right whereas for example
um something like Cloud submit is
submitting something to be executed in
the cloud okay you know what why don't
we fork off another meeting to discuss
this to clean up any other thing that
still needs to be done with the main
things we were talking about and then to
deal with this device submit stuff okay
and if ego was once it needed to be
involved please make sure he's in the
meeting so we don't have a three-way yes
okay great and okay let's get Pat I sent
you this notebook thank you for the
comments from the livestream thanks uber
anything else okay see y'all soon okay
bye